it's really a circular pattern
you have legitimate chemicals made by
american chemical companies
making their way illegally into the
supply chains
that lead to illegal laboratories
in colombia they produce cocaine in
mexico they produce heroin
or meth
and these narcotics make their way back
in a circular motion
all the way back to the united states
and europe where they're consumed a
great profit to the cartels
the subject of american chemical
companies fueling drug production in
latin america is a pretty sensitive one
even though it's been around for a long
time
when we were investigating the whole
package of everything that was happening
in this space
one of the best leads that i came up
with
was a small police unit in ecuador
that we had never heard of and that we
had no idea existed that gets funding
from the us government
and they were up against an
extraordinary wave of chemicals being
trafficked through ecuador
we didn't have any idea that the heart
of what they were up against
involved one of the biggest deployments
of border forces in latin america
and sparked a small war along the border
between
ecuador and colombia with this full-time
drug lord
[Music]
on january 27 2018 in the early hours of
the morning
there was a massive explosion in a town
called san lorenzo
[Music]
[Applause]
a stolen mazda pickup truck packed with
explosives
went off and it just created a path of
destruction
about a thousand feet in diameter
you have to understand it was the first
car bombing ever in the country
and it was a really shocking event
in the end there were dozens of people
who were wounded and the
focus of the explosion was a police
station the main police station in that
town
an explosion destroyed
the police were completely sure of who
was responsible this
and they ended up blaming a well-known
drug trafficker in the region
and his name was walter arizala
but everybody really knew him by his nom
de guerre
which is
[Music]
once the police assigned blame for this
horrible explosion
they started to ask why
and that led them back a few days before
the bombing
when a special police unit in ecuador
had come upon a massive
cache of specialized chemicals
that are used in the production of
cocaine and that chemical is called
calcium chloride
calcium chloride is kind of a strange
chemical to think of
when you think about cocaine it's a very
commonly used chemical
for many many different very legitimate
things for example
melting ice on streets keeping dust down
on
places like tennis courts but
in recent years the chemists that
produce cocaine in colombia that shipped
all over the world
found a really good use for this
particular common chemical calcium
chloride
to make cocaine requires many many
different chemicals and solvents
that are used to extract
the key ingredient cocaine from the coca
plant
these are regulated under international
drug laws so they're hard to get
cartel chemists can use calcium chloride
to recover
and recycle the heavily regulated
solvents
they need that means the chemical gives
them a back door for bypassing drug laws
they can use the even more important
chemicals over and over again without
having to find more
as a result of this being one of the key
chemicals in the production chain of of
cocaine
police in ecuador and colombia have
focused intensively on seizing
that chemical so that it doesn't get to
the the clandestine labs there in the
jungles of colombia
because once you take that out of the
production chain
it makes it a lot harder to actually
produce the quantities of cocaine that
they need to produce
to fulfill demand around the world
so the police in ecuador formed a
special unit
solely dedicated to seizing drug making
chemicals
that's what they've been doing so
they've been quite effective
and despite these massive seizures you
still
had massive volumes of this getting
through enough
for the cocaine labs to make huge
amounts of cocaine
over the last few years one thing that
has surprised the police for these last
couple of years when they've been
focusing on seizing
is they kept seeing the same brand of
calcium chloride packed in the same bag
straight from the factory of the company
that made it
time and time again in the back of
trucks and they called it finnish
meaning finland and that's because this
stuff was made in finland
by this company called tetra well the
company called tetra
is actually a company based in the
united states just outside houston and
it's a major
chemical company and one of the
factories they have is in finland
and that's where all this stuff was
coming from
calcium chloride takes quite an amazing
route
to get to the chemical labs in colombia
it starts in
finland at tetras factory there where
they actually make calcium chloride
one of the biggest factors in the world
then it's shipped all the way to peru
to a single company that buys it in
massive quantities
and then it moves across peru to the
border of ecuador
and is smuggled across the border
basically in plain sight
and then it goes by truck all the way up
across ecuador and into colombia to what
is basically the biggest cocaine
producing region in the world
[Music]
tetra is not just in the chemical
business it's in the oil
and gas services business and one of the
chemicals that's really critical in the
oil and gas business
is calcium chloride it uses it in
fracking and
other fossil fuel operations and then it
has like this whole
other side business of selling calcium
chloride and sacs
to the food industry to the construction
industry
to the road de-icing industry
to airports using it for water
purification
and when the fossil fuel business goes
down they really
rely on these other industrial sales
to keep their sales up
so we were trying to figure out why its
sales of calcium chloride
had just really exploded to peru which
was the fountainhead
of all the trafficking that was
happening through ecuador and
into colombia and it was just a single
distributor
we started looking through their
financial statements conferences that
they did with investors and analysts
and we found just a basic description
from one of their vice presidents
saying their oil and gas industry had
suffered so much
because just fell into a slump in the
u.s especially fracking
and so they were really pushing sales in
every other area where they could sell
calcium chloride
as much as possible and that had driven
i think a 24
boom in their sales overall globally
from about 2013 through 2017
at the exact period that we saw these
sales were really dramatically
increasing
to a single importer in peru and so
the company's position was really that
because it wasn't regulated in peru
that all of its sales to peru were
completely legal
and that they didn't have anything to
worry about the irony was the u.s
government was
paying this police unit in ecuador
to drain this illicit pipeline while at
the same time a u.s company was
filling and refilling that pipeline
through ecuador
through these booming sales and the more
they knocked it down
it just kept coming back up again
because it kept getting refilled
again and again and again and it seemed
in the end
like nothing could stop it if the
company wasn't going to
try to control its sales
[Music]
ecuador is in a very strategic place in
the
cocaine trade it's not a producer of the
drug or
of the supplies that go into it but it's
strategically placed between
the biggest regions for producing coca
and
transporting cocaine out of south
america to the united states especially
it's really overwhelmed the country in a
lot of ways in terms of the violence
that is brought
cartels fight violently to keep
their trade at the center of all this
is walter arizala who's known as
he came to dominate the cocaine trade in
that particular region which is the
largest coca-producing region in the
world and he was
brought up in a very uh desperately poor
part of ecuador
and it was also in the heart of the
civil war that was going on in colombia
under a guerrilla movement called the
farc farc commanders
recruited arizala as a as a fighter when
he was just a teenager
he quickly became very adept at helping
the farc
manage the cocaine operation they had in
that area
which was a key element that was used to
fund the war that they were fighting
he was a very good military commander as
well and he was good at running a
cocaine operation
so that's that's how he came to become
the principal drug lord in that region
and came to be the protagonist behind
this wave of violence that came after
now a conflict that's lasted more than
50 years and cost more than
200 000 lives may be closer to ending
colombia's president and the leader of
the farc
rebel group signed a ceasefire agreement
today
in 2016 the farc guerrilla group
basically agreed to lay down their arms
and disband
in sort of a peace deal with colombia
but arizala
didn't want to leave the drug trade and
he took
100 fighters under his command and
basically created his own private army
to protect the drug trade in that region
it basically is one of the largest
cocaine production cartels in the world
he did that very successfully for a long
time until the police in ecuador and
colombia started really cracking down on
his operation
by the end of 2017 they'd arrested a lot
of his top
lieutenants including the man who
basically was responsible for
acquiring the chemicals he needed for
his drug labs
they were making massive seizures of
chemicals especially calcium chloride
this drug lord aristala was determined
to regain control
over that region and over his cocaine
and he began
actually chatting via what's up with the
police commanders in this town of san
lorenzo
saying give me my men back that you just
arrested
give me my drugs give me my chemicals or
there's going to be trouble
and so this went on for quite some time
so the police
were worried something was coming but in
the end they couldn't do anything to
stop it
and that's when this pickup truck
exploded which started what became a war
along the border
that pressure came to a head towards the
end of 2018
when they essentially cornered adisala
and some of his men
in colombia in the jungle and ended up
shooting him dead
they basically had gotten the most
wanted band in colombia at that time
but the drug trade didn't shut down
someone
stepped in and took control of the
massive cocaine producing empire that he
lorded over
they kept cranking on the drugs which
means
that their labs kept working which means
the chemicals kept coming
and we know this because the police
commanders in ecuador
since he got killed have been seizing
basically regular major shipments of
calcium chloride
time and time again so even though this
chemical which was being sold
by a u.s company was fueling all of this
trafficking the war on the border
it seemed like nothing could stop it and
it was all
just kind of this circular trade the u.s
pain
ecuador and police to drain the pipeline
and a u.s company refilling it again
over and over and
despite the irony and the circularity of
what we were seeing
in south america with tetra and its
product
it certainly wasn't the only u.s
chemical company that we found
whose legal sales were being easily
tapped by drug syndicates
to produce the deadliest drugs that were
being sold on the streets of america
in the 1980s there was a flood of
cocaine production
from latin america into the united
states an epidemic of crack in new york
is now out of control do you have no
words to describe how bad it is
the cia and the drug enforcement
administration in the u.s
made a rather embarrassing discovery
that about 95
of the chemicals that were used to make
cocaine
in south america for the us all came
from
american chemical companies there's a
list
called the red list at the very top is a
chemical called
acetic anhydride and it is the only
critical
essential chemical that you need to make
heroin
and under international drug laws it's
one of the most highly controlled of
these chemicals
sold anywhere in the world except mexico
i went into this medical supply store
with a mexican colleague
and we bought a one liter bottle of jt
baker acetic anhydride
and the seller volunteered to us that he
could easily get us
an 18 liter jug with that one 18 liter
jug that you can buy
for about 300 you can make about a
million dollars worth of heroin
the company was able to say that it did
everything
perfectly legally having us companies
involved in that
even if it's unknowing it just seems
extraordinary to us
[Music]
you